crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though Orion's like the
soccer star JUCO above ground crew goes
better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnosed go download this week
last week here we go again for the crab
feast
I want you to the crab faith y'all
Tuesday Tuesday Tuesday what does its
other crap ease without a ham oh man it
was like a grand finale going off door
to fireworks and i gotta tell you we're
right on into that pitch touch yeah
that's like sliding my feet on my whole
comfortable pair of slippers right there
I'm not good yet nice slippers on I
guess what are they called me when you
were in your night pants my tempurpedic
swim for my night pants [ __ ] yeah man I
watched I caught Deion Sanders on set I
was watching it but I caught him on set
come around from behind the thing he's
got his temper pedic saan with one of
his suits that's what you're wearing on
the sunset because you can't see it he's
comfortable as [ __ ] up there neon deion
son good to see a Jay Larson [ __ ] good
to be here with your sickle cell Jay
Larson here Jay Larson comic com Jay
Larson common in all social media only
dates unplugging right now our crab
feast tour dates and we are heading out
on the road sickle cell tone Raisa clone
Twitter Instagram and Facebook Ryan
Sickler calm and just before we hit the
road this weekend Saturday September
24th we have a live crab feast podcast
at LA pod fest which is going on all
weekend Friday Saturday Sunday live crab
feast podcasts from seven to nine with
Joseph Fink and Jeffrey Cranor I hope
I'm saying that right if I don't if I'm
not I apologize Jeff of welcome to night
Vale there are guest hugely popular oh
man I'm so stoked for this these guys
the imaginations they have hell I don't
even care if the stories aren't real I
I'd like to hear something from the town
you know I mean hey um there will be a
live stream live stream in every room
all podcasts will be on the website for
30 days and the price for entire
weekends 25 bucks but you know that Jay
Larson discounted at five off man mom go
to LA pod fest com to purchase the live
stream enter our promo code crab feast
for the discount go do it seriously
fight I mean what 20 bucks for chance
two days of contents it come on and then
the crab feast fall tour kicks off Oh
October 18 San Francisco punchline
Sanford
let's go come out it's one night get
your friends come on out I came up there
last time you guys pack the place out so
I hope to see you come out and give Jay
Larson the same love Sacramento punch
line on october 19th the next night San
Francisco Sacramento one-nighters it's
all in the Sacramento a lot of features
came out when I was up there for a
weekend last summer so come on out one
night and hang out with us let's have
some fun October 21st the Windy City
Chicago Wendy just added a second show
uh those tickets are going fast for the
first show so you might want to start
snagging up a second show october 22nd
very excited to be back in st. Louis
that's going to be a fun time that's
going to be I can't wait yeah saint-lo I
know I'm telling you this was a great
show and a great venue so November fifth
my first time Asheville North Carolina
I'm very excited to come down asheville
north carolina on November fifth and
then we go up to jail our sins neck of
the woods in town on november six laughs
boston laughs ball get out for that and
then on the 8th gonna be new york city
at carolines on broadway that's right
all you new york Feaster's come out hang
out with us it's it's election day so
you know get your ballots in in early
come on we're telling you now telling
you now one night only November night
Philadelphia helium comedy club very
excited to go to Philadelphia and do
some standup November 10th the nation's
capital drafthouse comedy in Washington
desa dasa and then November 11 11 11
yard pit of the u.s. baby no Baltimore
Maryland and we are very close to adding
a Denver show right now we're working
talking to a venue right now we're going
to hopefully lock that down for November
date as well tickets for all shows are
available on Ryan Sickler calm and the
crab feast doc make a night of it
calling my friends get your people
together if your dad needs a laugh your
mom needs a laugh you cousin bring
people out let them know what their let
them know what it is when you're going
around being like hihi plan
what is that he's always saying no no
none Tourette's exactly so get out there
get everybody out let's make it a tour
remember I can't wait to come out on
stage to hear the hey hey players and
the [ __ ] the crab feast into Tuesday's I
mean I hope the fan we get a lot of it
now uh but we've not been to most of
these cities you know when like a guy
hits a home run like in his rookie
season they just like no one even
congratulate some I hope that's what
they do act like they throw the ball out
up into the plug of it they just don't
do anything if you guys all got together
just folded your arms and sat in silence
for an hour you know we'd appreciate you
um merch is back we just got you guys
are tearing it up we just restocked so
we'll be there's plenty of stuff coming
for you amazon link always thank you for
using that bridgetown premium app is
going through what it's got the process
right now so first up I hope it's a week
process process my bad facebook fanpage
follow us there to keep up with all the
tour info and iTunes page great sponsors
week indochino custom menswear guys
they're doing it right talk about the
best quality you can get in a men's suit
if you need a suit you don't just have
us everybody's you have a suit from like
right ten years like luck this is time
to get it they have a personal
experience with indochino it's fitted
okay it's when the largest
made-to-measure menswear brands there's
a big difference between buying
something off the rack and then just
getting a fitted shirt fitted suit and
that's what they do so you don't want to
look like Frankenstein that's what I'm
saying sickle cell they make it easy for
men to get great fitting high quality
suits and shirts at an incredible price
this is how it works visit indochino
calm or drop by one of their nine north
american showrooms that's
brick-and-mortar pick from hundreds of
fabrics and patterns choose your
customizations from lapels depletes
jacket linings and more submit your body
measurements kick back relax and you're
ready to step into the best no stylish
that you've ever worn or the one first
one you've ever won in just four weeks
this is how we do it our listeners can
get any premium indochino suit for just
389 @ indochino calm when entering the
code crab CRA be at check
that's fifty percent off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
that is an amazing deal if you've ever
had to buy a suit yeah let me not
getting added a competitor you're not
even getting that one of the like
warehouse places or come on nothing plus
shipping is free your satisfaction is
guaranteed to your money back there no
Chino dot-com promo code crab crb for
any premium suit for just 3 89 and free
shipping you'll never have to worry
about badly fitting suits are expensive
trips the tailor again go get it and
we're gonna go get this episode this
week proud to have him on the podcast
haven't had them on before Greg guy
ladies and gentlemen first time achraf
ease please give a warm welcome for mr.
Chris Fairbanks was clapping for myself
yourself right now it's better to on the
recording gonna have you a great dad
thank you wait what's crab feast ever
Voltron yeah what way back when I
started to see I don't last crab yeah I
i I've great podcast memory yeah you do
anyway it's better now short term
horrible podcast unbelievable yeah yeah
I'm denial I can't remember what we're
talking about right now but I know the
first guy ever made a podcast oh yeah
Pizza I'm just kidding that was opposed
to be you yeah I feel like it was that
jimmy pardo maybe faridah was early yeah
he was early on um well it's great to
have you here and Before we jump into
things why don't you tell everybody
anything you'd like them to know about
you your your social media your podcast
and then you can give your hey hey play
a shout out of the week okay so yeah
right now i'll just give you all my info
and then after a while that can decide
whether or not to look it up yeah yeah
I'm at Chris Fairbanks on the twitter
i'm at chris underscore Fairbanks on
instagram that Horton who's the regular
dude I don't know some guy that fixes
cars or something and he didn't go for
twitter though no no I there's a lot of
Chris Fairbanks is one guy's a
bodybuilder champion bodybuilder another
guy's a fireman that did some stuff on
911 and
and you can google him and find and then
there's a Chris Fairbanks that's an
actor in LA actually when I moved here
he's like we got problem we I am DP
we're gonna we're gonna go figure this
out he said he goes by Christopher and I
go by Chris that's what and you're like
listen man that's not our biggest
problem our biggest problem is this
freaking weightlifter dude yeah yeahs
was brush all right now he's waiting
clean and jerk I wanted yeah it'd be
great i wanted to pitch some reality
show called the Chris Fairbanks show
where I just live with these other Chris
Fairbanks is we have another in common
didn't somebody documentary will they go
to every town and they look up their
name the phone book and then they call a
person they go meet them or something
like that every idea I have has already
happened now that's a great idea for a
documentary see I used to whenever I
would fly places I would always go back
to the phone booth at the airport not
always look up sick leurs not
necessarily looking for my name just how
many uh how thick it was in that section
of the wherever he went yeah justjust
but i love the Chris Fairbanks oh that's
a [ __ ] great idea yeah I pitched it I
pitched it to three ball they made out
of the biggest loser and all that stuff
yeah they wouldn't they weren't biting
there like well one has to be famous
that's exactly what nobody knows this
crisp air bag I'll be damn sure don't
note about how these Chris Fairbanks is
a very famous the firemen just auctioned
off he was a celebrity auction ER at
this tractor auction tell me that's not
fair this game is somewhere yeah I'll
tell you we got a special special guest
for you today Chris Fairbanks he's
literally still waiting for uh having
two guys rolling yeah he's like statute
all the other chris merriman the other
Chris Fairbanks looks like a bold from
Night Court god I remember bowl from
Night Court yeah yeah I remember
nightcore yeah like a great show it was
great show yeah um so do you want to
plug away their unlikely gig for a
magician what was its name Harry
Anderson area let's plug Harry Anderson
no I want to plug my friend oh hey hey
playa shell Lance Lando Hughes from
Missoula Montana his Twitter's role for
damaged a troll
for damage let me ro ll yeah it's so our
I think I think we know it's probably
something to do with the dungeons and
dragons oh sure I was thinking it was
more auto body work it was like a diving
role if you want to talk yeah role for
damage Lando Hughes if you want to talk
to him about gaming or being a father or
just being a hilarious well tell it to
loud seven-foot tall yeah mine have a
piece seven feet huh he not quite he's
66 maybe he's a big dude yeah and and
he's basically the glue that keeps all
my friend like when I visit home he's
like everyone we're going out tonight
chris is in town all 15 of us are doing
this and they're like oh right and
everyone he like makes everyone that's
come out because you know every
everybody's got kids and obligations now
yeah less likely that they're all going
to show up at the airport like they used
to ten years ago sookie now yeah
Missoula I mean I've been to Missoula
I'm pretty sure it was the first place I
ever I know the first place of him I'm
just not sure if it's the only place
where I came to a four-way stop with no
stop there were no stop signs it was a
four-way intersection with not one stop
sign oh wow yeah I'm saying sure they're
basically like yeah we'll just all
figure it out you know I mean it's so
chill here like in neighborhoods sure
yeah yeah it's like no this was like
kind off downtown oh that's funny yeah i
can think of those intersections here
you just look to the right and if that
person's closer you let you let that
sounds like a montana guy yeah whereas
I'd be like who the [ __ ] this guy I'm
going punching it to get there quicker
yes sir Liam over here but yet the hell
dust rooster feather by or a tail bud I
have to uh yeah I have to adjust every
time I go home cuz everyone drives so
slow and cautiously and if you'd leap
into the street everyone stops are like
oh look at this guy jaywalking it's not
even you wouldn't get a ticket for it
even yeah yeah I drove from Seattle to
Montana and it was it's gorgeous there
like we saw Rams yeah the other ribs
it isn't see much of them but another
night uh now man i couldn't believe i
con the hillside i'm just like god yeah
you know i mean it's not sure you see
every day ya see that every day and they
are amazing they're like little tiny
hooves and they'll be on the side of a
cliff yes and they aren't stressed out
about it no just confident they're
waiting for somebody to take that
picture make a post yeah yeah some kind
of encouragement yeah they all just want
to be in an Ansel Adams how do I look
from this angle I really have no choice
I can't like turn around on this ledge
so you're from you're born in Montana
from Montana no i was born in the day
area carmel but we moved there when ice
little that's a Clint Eastwood used to
be though yeah actually my dad was a
radio guy and Clint Eastwood SAT and
watched him do radio because he was
doing that movie play misty for me where
he played a radio DJ really crazy yeah
it's like a fatal attraction type yeah
yeah yeah and but he said he watched the
movie knee Clint Clint ignored all is to
add company like lemmings good wit ya
[ __ ] look at always look how he's
clicking on the on switch wait a minute
did how many days did he go in and watch
your dad I don't know yeah he watched a
few guys that that work where it works
out I think maybe just for an afternoon
but he met him because of that what kind
of radio did your dad do ah morning
drive talk and music and in top 10 lists
and video Doreen did you look at Jamie
and back man look at not just Jim
Fairbanks just him forever and that's a
great radio and it is Jim Fairbanks look
on the morning drive then he had a damn
kid and they drove around tried to find
new radio jobs gave in and move to Mont
it back to Montana where he's from to do
what work for the government appraise uh
property wait a minute are you the kid
again when I'm one of the kids are you
want matter how many are you know yeah
my sister and I but I think it's like
you know that's prob I would be doing
stand-up you all right i had a career by
the time yeah you had kids but it'd be
hard to like still
be getting into a career and then have
kids and not decide well trust me i'm
still trying me you know yeah yeah still
right of it I commend you yeah I can
normally imagine I had a cat and it used
to transfer I descend the cat to my dad
yeah yeah it immediately died of AIDS
and that sounds like a joke but cadet
feline it it did really five with the
care you got to get a blood test and
they're like hey your cat as aids and
I'm like what I'm bringing it in there
like no he'll be fine you're dead so my
dad had to give him shots and medicine
your dad was like why you send me a lion
cat yeah thanks for the AIDS cat right
wasn't dying at the time he started us
at daddys HIV we don't know if it's
gonna turn I'm not pop just don't [ __ ]
him and neither is he I mean can it's
gotta be the worst question but can you
get anything from a cat that is that's
the first thing I said when I brought
the cat there I'm like I'm flying with
this cat tomorrow I want to sedate the
cat but I heard they can have heart
attacks no like yeah you have to test
the blood make sure they are wild a
dated some Tomcats just died and uh and
so she said yeah he's fine he's strong
he's a healthy cat he does have aids but
it's how and I'm like wait hold on and i
immediately thought of all the fleas cuz
when I live with tig she just started
feeding this cat on the porch and I'm
like if you feed that cat we have a cat
yeah you know he's not just gonna go to
the next house and sure enough he was in
my room but still like got fogged over I
and like bugs and [ __ ] on a missing
patches of hair oh so I his fleas with
yeah yeah total street cat that hung out
with possums like he was a wreck us play
harder love share his dish yet there's
like that velvet dog face no car
painting that's him an awesome dude and
he I had bites all over my ankles so I'm
like bugs have left this aids cat and
burrowed I know into my bloodstream
can't and she said oh you can't get aids
from a cat would and she get your face
trying to make funny line ages thought
our age like well it could be our key or
something it could sure that great be
yeah but that's not wholly also may
yeah maybe I'll get AIDS but I start you
know I got Rick yeah coughing up hair
yeah it's some weird but yeah and and
then I mentioned it uh to this lady on I
was getting on the plane with the cat
[ __ ] put me in first class
today at his home plate I mentioned the
cat at aids and I guess every I'm like
aids cat coming aboard but I said that's
lady I told it and I made a joke to her
but the whole plane heard me say aids
cat coming aboard and then you said yeah
yeah and they're all I got duly noted
and then on during the flight the cats
losing its mind really yeah that flight
his eyes were rolling back and his
tongue was out I'm like he's dying he's
having a stroke or heart attack so i
unzip the carrion thing and let him just
walk around while we're flying I'm like
what are they gonna land you know I was
worried about the cat and then I heard a
lady in bad go oh don't pet that cat he
has AIDS but she thought everyone thinks
you can get aids from a cat like it i'm
not the only idiot so I don't know why
this 18 came from monkeys so it's like
no I wouldn't at it either no aids came
from basketball in the 80s that's right
I wouldn't that's have you dad either on
a plane especially I wouldn't pet a dog
or anything on the precious strength
just walk I mean right on a place and
that thing's not just on your seat and
I'm getting next to you petting it that
thing's missing hair it's got a eyepatch
and it's rolling around yes smoking Lutz
looking for Paul's at this point in his
life he had cleaned up he looked pretty
good he's pretty healthy at all his hair
both eyes hey man nice lead us to did
him right yeah and he would go up he was
going up to people and not meowing he
used to hiss so that saved his life to
let him walk around I don't know but he
was calm after that and then just came
back and got back in the thing so I knew
he wouldn't it's a cat where a vice-like
hey come here he come come back most
cats are like let's look at it yeah how
long after your dad Gandhi he died about
a year I'm started going blind and I'm
like how this isn't good and then yeah
that damn heads sorry I really do feel
bad for bringing my dad nades cat I
thought he'd be you know retire in his
backyard with baby deer and
he's just got AIDS hanging on Rams and
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's what it is running
with the rim it's that cross speed cat
[ __ ] cross bridge well maybe it was a
little bit of payback for the stuff they
used to do to you when you were a kid
yeah exactly that's what it is take that
take that dad for being a perfect dad
what was he a great day yeah yeah it was
pretty good dad what's the story about
walking you to school oh yeah he well
that was more my mom they were just it's
a small town and you've been there there
isn't there's rarely even a light I mean
Missoula is a big town as far as Montana
goes sherry was like far as anything
else goes it's tight it's like 60 that
but there's cars going through and you
don't get hit so they dressed me up I
will walk to school my mom made me a
hunter's orange like a safety orange
vest and on the back which you made it
it it the vest was I think purchased
maybe at a gun safety course or
something it's like a hunting and then
on the back she with reflective tape
made like a stop sign no like an octagon
with the word stop on it on my back so
the cars coming at me I guess she
thought I would just zip around and show
my back point at my back okay slow down
turn around what's it say I don't know
we better slow down oh it's all y'all
stop sighs intersection but this one is
back and on my in my hand my dad made me
a stop sign flag on it on a stick like a
big a broomstick like a giant flag
flapping and hold on a second where do
they who do these two think they are
that they can just start giving people
traffic signals to walk around with I
know yeah exactly won't they just give
you a detour sign not yeah can't come
this way yeah yeah just yeah they I
think they knew I wouldn't abuse my
power I Jeffrey it was just so when I
got a wedding wool I could walk safely
until right at the school there's a busy
street there that did have lights but
there is a crossing guard working across
the street crocodile funk taunting much
that's what yeah exactly yeah we never
my phone nice vest
yeah yeah we talked about next day he's
got stopped what is it that's a good
idea yeah just taking style tips no it
was awkward it's like we had this
awkward standoff to see if I could cross
myself I'd like jump into the street
because I wanted it to be worth my time
wearing this thing so I try and cross
myself before they could get out of
their lawn chair got a flag you said Wow
where was your mom from my gloves man
they're both their back from uh from
Missoula yeah and then they moved to San
Francisco together uh yeah Bay Area yeah
gotcha yeah and then back yeah yeah and
then back as soon as uh so I mean but
it's so safe there they weren't thinking
all like he'll be fine they were more
cautious of like or do you become more
cautious so it's safe in that we don't
have gangs or whatever but everyone
knows that anytime Montana is on the
news I just cover my face because it's
going to be some guy eating children or
Holden you know the Unabomber stuff like
that it's always weird and there's
weirdos and when I as a kid they'd make
an announcement every month there was a
new it was always a white man but it's
like people are out there snatching up
kids and you gotta be on the lookout and
that's what I was scared of so I'm
wearing this stop I think I thought sort
of that the stop sign and everything
were four kidnappers like I thought it
was keeping me safe in that way that's
gonna get that kid but yeah yeah sounds
like ya clothes told me not to now I'm
just waving it around seductively I dare
you to stop thinking what you're
thinking but I think it's funny the way
you talk about Montana I feel like
people like kind of like the the way
brant older talks about Wyoming is like
you talk about it like it's my town that
I grew up and you're talking about the
whole state you know me like anytime
Montana's on the news right right you
know i mean if massachusetts on the news
oh my god what's going on like I don't
think of it like what's Massachusetts
doing I'm just like oh what's Matt
what's up with mass you know yeah yeah I
think I'm always rooting for missoula
Missoula the cool liberal arts college
town it's not it's different from the
rest of Montana it's the Austin of
aunt Anna sort of in my mind cuz you go
the rest of Montana and it's like oh
yeah people are with this five buildings
is the other place I've been oh yeah I
mean yeah I went for that big sky comedy
fest and it was like early 90s Missoula
like we went to this after party at a
bar and it was just multiple fistfights
really at once Judas big dumb cross-eyed
Cowboys punching each other and all
these la comics just horrified and I was
like oh home oh yeah i went to i was in
billings i was also in whitefish yeah
whitefish is really pretty that's that's
kind of like Missoula that was a redneck
bar Oh with the the owner's son in laws
band they were terrible but the
everybody kept on it's his son Roman and
he was terrible and on so the wall
behind him and then the two that came up
on the flanks here on these sides were
all the whole wall from ceiling to floor
was glass and behind it was every kind
of animal that they had killed and
stuffed I mean bears ram yak whatever
the [ __ ] it weights cat ain't over there
that one just kind of came to us yeah no
that's the air all in there the airport
you've if you did fly there now we drove
that's like a Tribble something early on
dubs just family we drove from I don't
see more people in Montana yeah it's at
the airport in Missoula has a giant in
encased in glass a grizzly bear that's
like the first thing you see when you
get off the plane you have to like get
be ready for it you live oh gosh oh the
TSA here I was there I'm cuz I was doing
a Tribble run that's why I was there and
then I remember like I stay with my
friends friends and they like we went
out walking the dogs like on a frozen
lake with like fishing huts everywhere
and then we drove to this bar that I'm
talking in the middle of nowhere and it
was just like Chile like happy hour with
chili great jukebox pool and beer and I
was like this is heaven yeah yeah yeah
it was so amazing just people cuz snow
like so packed in it was awesome sorry
snowing up there
when that's the only choice though
growing up you just want my whole life I
just want to live right where i am now
by the bead yeah well you're such a
beach cat to your skater and it's you'd
think but I I when I go home I my god
this is it is the best yeah to be in the
Rocky Mountains and and snow I love snow
I love driving in the snow yeah man I
love whether that's what we've seen
earlier because it was cloudy today and
I was like man I miss whether we
everyone here does seasons help bench
mark the passing at a time it's like oh
it's fall boy this is a long winter here
we all every year my odds my birthday
again god I'm getting old I think life
is like that in general but but I kids
in such Markham passing yeah yeah I got
out you're right I got it what were you
guys doing in high school like cuz we
guys like Evans doing like I imagine a
Montana you just get into [ __ ] yeah it's
different now it's like here now you
drive around downtown where everyone
just aimlessly used to cruise the drag
and it was just Cowboys listening to nwa
and giant trucks every are just white
kids with either Raiders hats or cowboy
hats driving around in their truck
wearing batting gloves looking for
fights that's all like early 90s was and
we would skate downtown and get in
fights all the time with Gary older
Cowboys it was and it's not that way
anymore at all like there's no one ya
like I you go downtown there's no and
they're like oh you can't can't drive
around at night are you crazy we're
about to get Eber though so that'll it's
like they're not yeah it's just kids
with tight pants on fixed gear bikes
just like anywhere else I think it's
good i don't think i think thats
everywhere i think the whole you forget
like you think just hipsters are here
and like los filos silver lake or like
Brooklyn and then you go to like other
small towns like 08 a man like even
Atlanta you were just there I remember
Elena I'm like oh it's just the same
kids just like that's the generation you
know yeah yeah or the same type of kids
that used to be bullied and didn't come
out of the [ __ ] house and now they're
not bullying they're out there yeah
right right yeah it's that but I know
that those kids are now all yeah
ever they do they do this thing with in
Atlanta it was even more stark like I
really notice not that I'm from there
but I did expect uh maybe a few black
people and there was no more they're
like being forced out it's like was
hipster where were you um because I was
in Atlanta walk around know so many
black people I was like I never felt
more comfortable in my life i guess i
was in a part that i was told by local
my friends there that that there should
be and always wear black people in this
area and then it had become a totally
lowes feel as type Barry White yeah my
man they're making new you know it's
just only high-end upper-class
apartments and condos that they're built
they're not even building middle-class
stuff it's just like pushing people out
I think every city's doing that I've
mixed feelings about it yeah of course
because uh cool maybe I can live there
now but also it's like how that really
sucks where these other people yeah yeah
I I'm split 50-50 so when did you when
did you leave montana and why did you
leave montana was a for comedy yeah I
had a improv group like we did the short
games a freeze tag and all that improv
come on we all love it now the games we
uh I in college eyes in some group and
we did little tours around idaho and
montana and washington this wasn't
improv sports or woza no we just I
didn't know what improv eyes had a party
and I was trying on this girl's clothes
and dancing around being a drunk and I
broke a lamp or something and then the
next she kicked us all out me and all my
friends and a couple days later in the
paper there was like hey guy it was like
a personal at you know uh-huh because
there was no social media beckons like
98 she's like you were at my party and I
kicked you out but you're funny do you
want to start an improv group and so I
you saw to the page I didn't know what
that meant was a blind throw out there
like yeah yeah oh it was all everybody
to check yeah yeah there was one hey do
you have leopard spots died in your hair
I haven't won a date and I'm like I have
leopard spot to my hair but I was too
scared my mom told me I should call it
be a loose lady no I uh yeah so she just
told oh no it's like whose line is it
anyway and I'm like oh that yeah I can
do that that's kind of how I started in
comedy is because of Eva Gilliam is her
name she she teaches improv in South
Africa now but um but yeah that's how we
started and then one of the girls in
that joined our group we started dating
and then she was moving to Austin to
teach it UT and I went weather and
that's where I started they've like
Austin's a great town just ya doing
stand-up so I kind of did improv there
for a while and then start doing
stand-up how long did you live there
about four and a half years hook and
then we her and I moved here from there
and lasted here about a year and then
broke up pretty amicably like so glad
this isn't we're like best course is
gonna be amiable because the breakups
could be all yes and yes and the whole
time right we should break up you know I
think you're right and you want I I
think I should take this off yeah that's
great yeah weird [ __ ] we're just playing
by the rules of improv I wasn't gonna
know but her yeah totally seriously like
I miss her I've tired of this long form
Harold uh yeah we you know split up all
our stuff and she start going on dates
with people I was still living there and
she was like I think going on dates like
we were trying to you listen I gotta be
amicable this yes yes yeah yeah but uh
yeah flip bring my back or just going
out oh no no she would never do that yes
in the bed with the three of them yeah
it's like this is getting ridiculous yes
yeah I know we're just roommates no okay
I'll hold us balls like ass she's were
you in different guys on the couch it
was just for a couple weeks yeah and
then uh and then I moved in with TIG was
just getting out of a thing so it worked
out but uh she we split up everything i
had to leave town to go feature on the
road and so we very quickly split
everything up clothes and ever we bought
some of the same clothes it's all she's
talked Anna so we had the same crossing
guard oven say
ain't no different yeah yeah and then I
she started seeing that this guy he's
I'd say he's on he was on Saturday Night
Live for a while Bill Hader she started
dating him before any of this was
happening we had both made tapes to be
on SNL and mine wasn't very good i saw
his performance at like m bar and I'm
like well they should hire that guy and
not me because he just does impressions
you know yeah it's like Schwarzenegger
and Pacino but still very good at them
and then he did get the gig and they
started dating and he's really nice i
saw him once and he was like hey um
thanks for the wife yeah she yeah
exactly it's like she's she had a good
time it was you know she said only says
nice things about my tanks for teacher
that whole ball cupcake and ship it
comes in handy literally yeah yeah yeah
he was nice but uh I'm watching him on
SNL that was cool too I'm like he's
nice-looking him doing a good job and
then at the end when they're like thanks
for watching Saturday Night Live good
night the whole cast is standing there
he was wearing one of my shirts like
he's wearing well technically was hurt
her yeah it was technically well shirt I
just wore it for seven years but I yeah
he was filling it out a little better
and everything I don't I wasn't jealousy
not jealous of them or they're you know
they're happy and have kids and stuff
now it's just weird to be watch an
article of your clothing kind of Trump
your career there's at least my shirt
major not Saturday Night Live Wow the
only way that could have another than me
getting the job yeah the last second
best thing how long ago was it just want
my clothes on oh that was a long time
ago yeah they have like you know they've
they've probably have kids going around
they're in high school or something now
now that was 2004 I honestly think an
amicable breakup is like one of the
greatest things in the world I always
used to think cuz I I mean I've had a
lot not a lot of breakups but all my
breakups I think the amicable you don't
mean but someone's always getting hurt
but I always want to be the guy that
could have the breakup or like I have
like a wife and they have
husband and we're still all friends and
we all hang out and [ __ ] like cable you
guys just date like I know crazy right I
mean I don't have that but I always
thought it was a cool dynamic yeah it is
a cool and I've been around it I'm like
that's like oh yeah I'm going over in my
ex's her husband just got promotion i'm
making chili it's like what and then
you're there and it's i I'm
uncomfortable I'm the only one that's
uncomfortable with it like I watches you
staff sex with your wife my friend isn't
that weird for you just the weird guy in
the kitchen that says that but I don't
yeah yeah I've had breakups that were
less amicable I've had terrible breakups
that ended up and punching whoa me
getting punched don't touch yeah no I'm
just taken you know yeah you wouldn't
even say that I get that what happened
cowboy got out of a truck yeah yeah
slide out back gone yeah maybe he
wouldn't call it a relationship but I
would I wasn't 2622 and saw ball but a
thousand on my face yeah batting you
know what I'm talking about batting yeah
yeah it's easier to punch people yeah
all me me and all my friends used to
have pepper spray my mom gave me pepper
spray and she's like if those guys
bother you again just spray him in the
face and punch him holding this
Wellspring my mom what's like yeah first
things first put up the yield sign yeah
they don't they don't use video she's it
was the same wave your flag same part of
her brain like that that's the key frame
and the physician two min when you punch
a make sure it's in the nose during that
you make it matter now I yeah around the
time my space I met some girl through
myspace yeah well I'm of money it was
during the during the heyday of my face
get pre top it was just when you had top
floor friends that era before you can
add before arguments do it friendships
end yeah and some beautiful young girl
was like hi I want to meet yous and I'm
like that's even then i thought i was
being what is catfish yeah I did but
this girl I met this girl and drove all
the way down to like San Juan Capistrano
and she's as beautiful to see the birds
company young girl yeah and I'm like do
you have a boyfriend cuts on her honored
my space there's some dude
had like a Tapout shirt and I'm like I
don't that's bad as Chris forever she's
like no we broke up yeah yeah we and so
I met her down there it was great and
then she came to Venice and we soberly
during the day got Ted matching tattoos
how long into this it's good oh I the
second date the second date yeah sober
you said it's covered with a band-aid
now but it's like a less than three
because she sent that on myspace now we
all know that's art but yeah back then I
was like that is that gotta love it yeah
looks like an ass sounds at least 60
yeah yeah it just look like an ass with
sideways asked with a birthday hat
coming or something I don't know I
didn't know what it was sorry I'm having
a heart attack it's the Lacroix bubbles
there you go uh anyway so the way you
guys whose idea I i'm gonna guess it was
dared to me yeah she's like a dairy and
I'm like on my ankle okay I wear socks
every people make fun of me I get
pointed at and laughed at in Hawaii for
wearing socks at every waking moment
even when I'm surfing and no no but I do
wear socks a lot and so I knew that I
could cover whatever was and I'm like
yeah I'll get a heart on my ankle chair
and and I was being dumb also yes she
was privacy for hot right she's yeah
she's very pretty I'm still a pretty
person but uh but so I she left he went
home the next day I camera it was either
tick or it was David huntzberger my
roommate let some guy knocked on the
door and I was getting dressed it was
the morning and i had no shirt on I was
just putting on my pants and some kid
comes in like 20 year old big dude got
right in my face in my bedroom and I was
like oh I don't who are you I don't he's
any said I came here to kick your ass
and and I was like and I had a coffee
mug I'm like maybe I can hit him with
but he was a big veiny kid and I was uh
I just started talking to him like his
dad or something I'm like this is do you
realize how much trouble you could get
in for you're in my home rustic yard
you're in my home this is great is this
is this about what's-her-name are you do
you know her and he said yeah I mean
we're we've broken up I'm like well then
why are you here that's crazy and then
he started giving me a seat have a seat
did damn right he said thank you he was
like shake he was like just know that
she's very manipulative if you start
gaining or you're in for a world of like
she really hurt and I'm like I'm sorry
man out I even put had my hand on his
shoulder furman look at this tattoo I
got a mile that's how he found me he on
on her phone he looked at her phone
while she is showering on the phone it
was me sending him her my address and
then a picture of our matching tattoos
um so that backed up he's like there's
my address i'm driving there right now
he drove from Omo almost San Diego to my
house in the morning and got and he was
gonna any was like trying to make he's
like why'd your room all messy I thought
you were like a mr. TV cuz eyes on like
fuel TV at the time and you knew he was
like in that world because we had MMA
fighters on dudes he fought were on our
show like he was into fighting oh my god
and totally what it killed me but he's
like yeah your rooms messy oh sorry if
I'd known you're coming here to beat me
up i would have spruced up a place like
looks better than but he finally after
like an hour left wait and did it become
like calm yeah yeah yeah he would not
leave and when he left i'm like hey
huntzberger that guy you let in came to
beat me up and he's like I just seemed
like one of your friends he just said
his Chris here and uh but he yeah I
didn't and then I kept seeing that girl
after a while like she's like I'm so
sorry that happened he's jealous we
still live together because i have this
cat hairless cat it's a goddamn another
cat story yeah cats all over you that he
became yeah he became like well known
for like water like skydiving in the
squirrel suit like redbull diving off a
cliff face of the lunatic you know this
dude dude yeah yeah like was known i
didn't know how known until he died
doing it he did yeah he was like in
Chile Chile or a bit by a mountain life
no you [ __ ] hit the side yeah just a
goat he clipped a goat then
for my picture and then uh but he died
so i guess but wait how big cuz I mean
that thing looks you gotta be you gotta
be a little off your I mean how do you
try that the first either yet I think he
started with BASE jumping I know that he
was parachuting she went with him once
which was a point of content I was like
really your skydiving with your ex she's
like do you want to and I'm like no no
go with him yeah whatever set but yeah
he jumped I think he's BASE jumping
maybe and died and I looked in the read
the story it's like red bull-sponsored
champion like it was a big deal people
know who he is the aunt died so the
point is don't [ __ ] with me you know
come back yeah yeah I'll find a way I
never had anyone I had a guy come to me
in high school one time and try to fight
me but he never got past the door and he
all his buddies are in the car like kick
his folk enough sweetie like yelling
knew him like and I was a freshman and
sophomores and they were all in the
football team and they were all jacked
and I'm sorry I just had to like talk my
way out of it cuz I thought I was gonna
get beat down on my front steps yeah
I've always been able to talk my self
doubt he knew I was and he was night I
I'd seen him after that because he went
with another athlete to the daily habit
and I was like hey remember that time
you came to my house and he's like ah
it's so embarrassing like oh he's a nice
dude I was said yeah when I saw that he
died I was actually kind of sad oh
that's the unfunny version yeah yeah
also let me say died one of your
t-shirts or something like that yeah
that credit yeah that's the second
second time one of my shirts got famous
uh tell us about this oh yeah that's
yeah that that's that is that yeah what
happened with her oh I yeah she we both
covered our tattoos and she covered hers
yeah yeah sure has a rose I got a
band-aid I thought a bandit I think
band-aids a pretty good talk you
literally had a bit that is a girl yeah
yeah to cover like a mistake tattoo yeah
i was thinking of getting other bad ones
like on my knees and elbows just so i
could get the band in but I could just
get the bandage yeah but I'd like that
you where you can see faintly
the old tattoo underneath it in so it
has perfect soldier yeah so I just get
more emoticon tattoos and then wait that
last like a year with her off and on I
mean up there was years later where we
tried again you know yeah gives I can
show that we're close yeah it's like
these things happen and people do
terrible things but you so you don't
know them and I'm bad it I always stay
in touch with that says I don't know why
I do that you don't burn a lot of
bridges I try not to are you put your
foot in your mouth a lot yeah yeah yeah
every five minutes but I want those
bridges I'd like to maintain
relationships where I'll be consistently
putting my foot in my mouth for as long
as possible yeah and people appreciate
about you yeah you need the bridges get
the [ __ ] out of there yeah I know yeah
love like yeah it's the same part of me
that when I'm doing stand-up I oh I only
focus on the one guy in the crowd who
isn't enjoying himself if there's a guy
like a [ __ ] has his arms crossed he's
sitting right up front all my focus
unhealthily goes towards that guy at the
expected the expense of everyone else
enjoying the jokes I'm like what's let's
talk to this guy for a minute let me
ruin the show just because I can't have
this guy not likely I think I'll do that
person is the time cuz you want he's
like don't you get a man my goal is to
make everyone like yeah yeah now I gotta
just be like 92 per cents a great number
I also get off on ignoring that person
because they know they're waiting for
you to say something and I get off on
ignoring them and then making these
people around them laugh even harder
yeah that is it bothers that's more
healthy to do yeah i mean i don't always
do it they don't usually no one notices
him unless he start tackling that's a
difference he's he's an idiot on twitter
that sends something to you and if you
don't reply or respond or engage no one
except for the [ __ ] at eight people that
follow him would even know what [ __ ]
happened yeah yeah yeah yeah um these
people so Jay had asked you about some
stories before we started and you said
that you had a car wreck but that's at
such a significant time too oh hey
everybody just you know in light like
when you're like well it just makes
sense to after what he just said yeah i
mean with some
something good happens my whole life I
braced myself then for something bad to
happen I've always felt like there has
to be some balance yeah are you guys
like that like or if something bad
happens you're like well this today
something Goods gonna happen to back
this up I used to be like that a lot I
used to always think well I used to
always believe just good things would
happen and then it got to a point where
like some good things it would always
lead to some good to some bad but it was
normally like you said I was [ __ ] it
up because good things were happening
and I just didn't know how to accept
good things because I was never right
used to it yeah that's me was like when
you meet people that like grew up either
rich or successful or with healthy
parents and then just like have their
life like 22 years older like yeah I
start a business at 18 and now I'm
trying now i'm trying sailing I think
sailing that you know I sold that
business and just like that you have no
superstitions are you just enjoying
every moment exam lunatic yeah yeah I
found like fifty dollars on the ground I
would avoid spending it or stay indoors
the next day just cuz I'm like whatever
I spend this on its gonna can escape or
I'm gonna break my ankle you know like I
always felt like that oh yeah I did
Conan and it went great and I enjoyed it
and I was happy and he sent like one of
my jokes had to be edited because I'd
literally I messed up and I'm like I'm
gonna redo that hoping that and they did
cut that little part out so he sent me
the edit and I was listening to it on my
phone as we were pulling out stopped at
a light and then some dude going 55 just
crushed pulling off cars and yeah with
what my ex was driving that's a little
tiny honda fit and wii boat yeah we got
it was bad i was like in a lot of pain
for like a month just like stiff i
didn't i know it was comin though i was
like all loose I think about it you know
know there's notes if I heard I wonder
if if I had heard the brakes and kind of
braced myself cuz he didn't skid or
anything he was just going looking at
his phone or something oh and i think if
you tense up I hear that's when you like
break bones yeah it's just this a drunk
drivers yeah
get out of it because they're fully
relaxed or asleep or something yeah I
was relaxed and felt good all the
nervous is dis Conan yeah yeah it's like
all right and then almost didn't get the
watch I remember the thing the glove box
when we got hit the glove box flew open
and I remember a pen stuff flying out
there and then once we got hit the pen
stuck oddly in the in the vent for the
air conditioning like some like a god
like an arrow in my face went like right
next door and that was the first thing I
was like that pen almost poked out my
eye are you all right like I just we
were trapped in there the doors where
and she was okay yeah yeah I mean we
just were both at she's made up yeah
yeah that's all my stories do program
just oh yeah all i did is talk about
different people that dies in this life
now she she's doing great uh and the
driver was okay too she wasn't yeah he
was he didn't the other car ya know that
far and then the one in front of us oh
the yeah the dude in front of us was
like from some not another teen movie or
something he's like this actor as like i
finally pried the door open and pulled
her out of the window and then he was
he's like are you guys okay and I'm like
you were in that when you were a kid you
were that redhead doesn't get me out of
here yeah yeah I before I helped her my
girl sorry honey yeah so yeah all those
call all three cars totaled and yeah and
then re i think that coming out of that
I'm i have to get my hip replaced now
and we're pleased i think it's because i
was walking we i already had hip issues
probably because he said it was all worn
out from the cowboy I didn't start
feeling it yeah from all those Cowboys
just going bareback I know from all the
guy Cowboys but you have to give me the
blue it's on you yeah yeah I'm both of
them yeah it's amazing and i don't i
don't think it's cuz of that car wreck
but i do think that's when I started
feeling it cause didn't help yeah yeah
if you start like my ribs hurt my back
hurts and you start walking kind of
crooked i however i relearned how to
comfortably walk it start
[ __ ] out my and there you go get a
hip replacement I can't wait yeah it's
now to the point where I'm like let's do
it tomorrow cuz all he's doing is taking
a [ __ ] little motorcycle helmet like
a cap like a metal cap on the ball joint
like you keep all your original uh
product just cap it yeah yeah so it's
not a full replacement Chris listen
before we get to the serger here I
looked over your blood work and if cat
aids I'm sorry I went straight to your
hips might be that I am you were talking
about doing good and and you know
waiting for whatever for the other foot
to drop made me or getting yang and two
times recently very recently actually
and within probably only a week of each
other or two i readed myself last Sunday
I went got a spa day went to Burke
Williams after the [ __ ] spa day I
tried that tell you about what happened
to me know Oh bad so her mother's day I
decided you teach you something they're
doing their things I'm going to [ __ ]
do a spa day yeah this was the end of
the day and I go and everybody every
woman I work with or talk to or I was
asking them about spas like don't go to
Burke Williams go to the Korean day spas
there's so much cheaper and they're the
same thing and I'm like okay all women
right so I pull up this one Koreatown
here and it's got you walk in it's got a
driving range a little short driving
range here on the left a lot of like
other [ __ ] going you make a day of
horseshoes what's this specific one
recommended or did you yes this one will
recommend yeah yeah but again
recommended by women who don't go to
this one right so I go in and it's to
these two Korean ladies and I can't
understand anything they're saying to me
I'm like listen I've never been here
before consume I take me back there and
show me and they all I can understand
was they said you'll figure it out no I
walk in and I'm telling you it their
minds their might as well have been 500
dicks in the air it was dicks everywhere
and I was like
oh of course this is a place for gay
guys mostly to hang out meet now I'm not
talking about [ __ ] or anything but to
meet one another and then go out after
that's not where I saw this going down
yeah neither maybe I was like what the
[ __ ] going on my mother's day so I
know it and they tell me like your
masseuse is gonna come and get you at
like ten of one you keep an eye on the
clock you're in the hot tub do it
everyone and here's your partner that
you're assigned all that it's gotta be
taped to your back so um I'm in the hot
tub and oh my god it's almost ten and
one so I go and this guy comes and gets
me and I my guys probably the guy taking
me to the other place where this lady's
gonna massage me oh it's him it's him
this dude [ __ ] it throws me down at a
table just start splashing me with
buckets I'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on here so they get out the leaves and
[ __ ] I dude it was he was scrubbing me
hard and just and then just bucketing
the [ __ ] off of me onto the floor
understanding that we're all walking in
this I'm that's part of it though right
that's so far that's massage based
treatment yeah but I'm saying like it
wasn't sanitary like you're just taking
everyone's dead skin cells and bucketing
it all onto the floor if I didn't know
I'd have my own room yes it was like
eight other dude haha to left and right
of me amazing with dudes massaging dude
just so that I go take your Stender like
go shower so you shower you come back
and they do more and I'm like you know
oh my god uh and I'm like oh man and the
thought crossed my mind like what my
[ __ ] dick gets hard during this and
I'm face down and in that little hole
you know what I mean and I look and I
see his toes and toenails it was the
nesting should ever see it I was like my
dick was like you don't need to worry
did you get the whole massage yeah we're
gonna leave in the middle of it yeah I
got the whole goddamn was hot he was
taking my ball bag of moving it out of
the way like that was just you know what
he did I was like this guy is either
loving his [ __ ] job or like what bad
career moves did he make along the way
to end up here this guy's just like like
it's his business all
everywhere and hard scrubbing the [ __ ]
out up and I was like man and I get done
and I'm like this sucks it's it was
dirty just sucked so I'm like I'm going
to Burke Williams why go to Burke
Williams well I get all the way there i
went from koreatown santa monica and
their own mother's day it's only open to
women I was like calm yeah thought so
just recently from may until now I
finally can go and I go and I'm great
day I'll uh you know it's just a great
place there anyway and as I'm leaving
there's I see a 20 on the ground and
then some scattered Dingles Burke
Williams is on the sidewalk outside and
I'm like this has to be it's gonna be
somebody filming this or whatever break
I snagged a 20 I put it in my pocket and
then I see like two fives and a couple
bills I go to grab it this little girl
and her sister come down and grab it and
don't let yours and i was like no it's
not it's just on the ground but yeah
it's fair out here let's split this
derelict you're so nice i was like i
said they don't know I had to 20 already
you know hey yeah yeah yeah that's so
great so then I go to the park on
Saturday I'm just walking getting laps
and stuff I'm there for like two hours I
try to walk for two hours and as I'm
walking I see this check on the ground
my comment it looks like somebody's
checked like a check and I'll open it up
it's a check for three thousand dollars
hand on the back Chris Fairbanks Chris
Fairbanks on the back to dude has
already signed it oh no yeah so I can
just sign my name and go [ __ ] deposit
if I want to but I look and I'm like on
its Oaks treat I'm like oh that's right
here so I put it in my gps the little
apple whatever your [ __ ] maps Sharon
I'm like oh man this is a quarter of a
mile so I walk to his house I beat on
the door nobody answers I could walk for
a little while Chris here yeah walk back
I beat on the door his [ __ ] stoner
kid opens it up he's like he just looks
at me us up did I drop something I go
yeah you drop something this and he's
like oh my god I've been looking for
that thank you i was like you dropped it
at the park over there amazing thank you
so much shut the door i walked away he
and break yo G nothing I was like
looking around I was like waiting I was
like that's what I went to rainbow acres
and was wearing gym shorts
my I felt my wallet fall out and I my
god that's exactly what looked folded up
and look like he pulled something else
out and that thing shot out yeah I and I
and I went to the jail I had a flight
that day too but I thought I'd swim real
quick and then I got the gym and
realized my wall was gone and it was on
the sidewalk like homeless people are
yelling at parking meters right in front
of rainbow acres here and I went back
there and it was gone and I'm like I
can't get on my plane the hundred or two
hundred dollars in there it's gone
credit cancel all my cards but then yes
some girl on Twitter it's like hey come
on I found your wallet on Twitter and
she lived around the corner I went and I
was a say my body builder but I was like
do please take this cash yeah it's like
I don't need it I'm like I be like we at
least follow me hey I I was riding my
bike one time in the valley on Chandler
one of my favorite streets in the valley
is the while ago and I see this credit
card laying in the street but it's at
the base of this driveway he's going up
to this nice ass house like all right I
walk up knock on the door I'm like think
he dropped his credit card records like
oh my god yes Emma broke me alone but
helpful shots at their basketball hoop
on the way out of the driveway and left
Katie damn i was just break off
something you gotta Kate's dad we're
just back in New York my family and my
father-in-law they leave the house and
we get a phone call uh did you find
Joe's wallet we're like what she's like
Joe lost his wallet we don't know where
it is can you check the coolers like
check the coolers because he brought
like coolers the beer and he's a nice
obsessed and ice down all the beers so I
checked the cools money has no wallet in
here no one finds a wallet he calls the
store as he went he calls everyone no
wallet we go we finished like we had
rented the house then we're gonna spend
one day with them before we leave go to
their house Joe found the wallet was in
the garage we're like oh that's great I
get to their house Kate's in the city
for work I'm gonna be with the kids at
the at my in-laws and I say I go I'm
gonna put Reed down for a nap I go Jean
will you take the baby I wanted to go
get an Italian sub I want an Italian sub
on back east and Joe so let me take you
to place I don't great place he gets now
he's just telling me about how he found
his wallet how exciting you know he's
telling the stories
then he starts telling he's like you
know one time I lost my phone he goes I
out the convertible I don't know how he
lost his phone how the car I don't say
because I lost the car and I lost my my
phone and I didn't know what to do Jay I
was driving around and I got a call
about 45 minutes late from the sky and
yes and uh he'd found he called my gene
his wife you know and got called her and
said I get a phone and I went to him and
I go cheese would you find goes well
these two teenagers found it and they
asked me if it was mine I said no but I
said I would find the right people and I
said and joe said owed you know where
they went and he goes yeah they you know
they went this way oh ok so he drove
around sees these two kids he's like hey
and like all these dudes over there just
like who is this whack job he goes did
you guys turn in a turn into cell phone
and they're like yeah and he broke him
off a 50 ok I'm a 50 left great and he
goes here you go you guys split this and
this is a reminder that if you ever lose
anything that you always return it ok I
know like okay I thought he's crazy
because he tells me he's like I keep a
50mm ology just for that emergency yeah
hit at that point I want to maybe keep
22 to bolt bulks of 25 each yeah I keep
it 50 just so two kids can awkwardly
split it at any point oh yeah I they can
have a fight but I was hiking Fryman
Canyon founded dudes as I'm walking i
found a dude's driver's license and i
just started and i was like i'm looking
at it and every time I pass somebody I'm
just seeing I'm waiting to see and then
I see I think I see him I'm like you
Gary he's like I am I go that's your ID
man he's a cop shouldn't even know I
dropped it nothing he should have been
like you Gary the Gaelic you son of a
[ __ ] good looking for you [ __ ] new
garrett III always return [ __ ] unless
its cash unless it's cat I mean sure I
was in fair coeur d'alene idaho cuz
anyone could go oh yeah that is worse
yeah and we're at a hotel was a family
and um I went out to the car we had
checked in the room are you and I went
back to the car to get something it's
nighttime and there's people like maybe
five or six parking spaces down there's
a wad of cash I mean a wad of cash just
sitting on the ground on a clip and I'm
looking at them and I'm like there's no
way it's there so i take it and they're
down aways i take
I look at on my cot damn it's like 350
bucks here so I go back to the room and
donning her mom like you needed to turn
that in and take it I was like I'm its
cash yeah I'm gonna go down to that
front desk kid and be like I think some
I lost says he's gonna I'll make sure
they get it he's gonna [ __ ] take it
there's no tracing that sure cash I
always keep unless I see a father your
[ __ ] pocket right I'm not a savage
sure sure no yeah that's not even the
issue its yet you don't want someone if
someone's going to steal it it's gonna
be me yeah or adopt it not even it's not
even stealing one time I in Austin with
the girl I moved there with that that
girlfriend at that time some guy called
my phone and said hey I found a purse
with an your phone number what's in it
and I'm like aw it's got me my
girlfriend's purse time I went to some
weird park the guy want to meet in a
park where I guess he found it which was
creepy and it was kind of it was
nighttime at night you and me yeah yeah
yeah well was when he found it if I see
yeah yeah meet me tonight yep Nate am
yeah yeah its my anniversary of the last
times died at my hands no he so I met
this guy and he gave me the parade
looked in all of her stuff was in their
wallet and and you know ID and
everything so I but I was the only phone
number in there I guess ah but then
right it's like thanks a lot man I'm
glad you found it but then he goes all
weirdly he goes to pretty girl nice like
oh man I'm like what I hadn't heard from
her I couldn't get ahold of her I'm just
meeting this guy in a park who now has
her stuff who goes pretty girl and I
haven't as far as I know she's dead or
his trunk so then I turned on him I'm
like what do you mean pretty girl what
do you what the [ __ ] is like I start
getting in his face and shaking and
thinking like this guy just murdered her
and if your pepper spray yeah and he's
weird and give me and I didn't have my
pepper spray on me because i usually
give it I get that's the best gift to
give any girl your wife give her pepper
spray just go down to the local this is
I know you're sponsored by that suit
thing but go to any army navy local army
navy get it gets
pepper spray and give it your pulse give
it to your lady friend so they can spray
someone right in the face anyway this
guy but he then he is weird he's like
you're a weirdo why are you freaking out
on me I'm like what do you mean pretty I
saw a picture in there she seems pretty
yeah but you said it all low and weird
like a weird murderer and it just ended
up off so it was like a prayer I'm like
thanks a lot offered him money he didn't
accept and then it right in the end I
just accused him of being a rapist
murder you like oh I'm leaving you gonna
walk away and you're walking the same
way I did yeah I just didn't know i'm
right next oh yeah yeah alright alright
and there yet right next to each other
that's how he lives next door to you oh
god yeah yeah it's that was uh but yeah
turns out he just found a person he was
not a murderer and he was a nice guy
yeah he's a nice guy as a little
socially awkward yep and a man did I
call him out on it learn how to talk to
people maybe I guess it's the takeaway
from this yeah well we're there at that
time and this has been a lot of fun
thank you so much for coming on shirts
or worse yeah we went all over my top I
got all of them sure promise perfect
timing um will you one more time promote
your podcast your social media whatever
you want sure sure my podcast is do you
need a ride uh Karen kill Gareth and I
in a studio now it's safer we used to
driver yeah tell them i love it i love
this i know i do too and i still wish we
could it was hard to orchestrate the the
picking up at the airport find a comic
every week that needed a ride then it
every week you tour in the morning you
take a comedian to and from well we used
to and we used in them for a while we're
just picking comics up in the car but
then that we almost killed a couple
people it's hard to multitask yeah it's
hard for me to drive and even talk I the
podcast is so much better now that we're
doing it at all things gamma D studio
like it's just a better podcast but now
the name fine the name doesn't make as
much sense we're not going to say things
transform ya yeah Thank You solidly
exactly it's exactly i can't think of a
example other than that but yeah I'll
thanks comedy do you need a ride Karen
kill Gareth and then my friend bland
Lando Hughes in Missoula Montana it's a
great father and he said I can I can
pick him up to he's like 300 pounds i
can put them on my shoulders good work I
can't pick up other why you have bad it
oh yeah it's definitely done things to
me every time I come home it's on the
heels of having him lifted him up at the
Stockman's bar and I've hurt my back
anyway he's great by his calendar even
though who years old what do you mean
he'll get allender yeah yeah just a
little photo shoot of him he's got a
12-month got 13 month calendar you don't
like this 13-month Ken yeah all they get
yeah well I was when he's 2017 gives you
time to get that done yeah but there are
13 month calendars are unlucky just like
that missing hotel floor yep sorry I
keep jacking that it's all right um
great to have you been great yes thank
you thank you for having me as always
Jay Larson calm be calm Jay Larson
comedy and all social media Ryan Sickler
on all social media Ryan Sickler calm
will talk to y'all next Tuesday